empieza la recta final de las elecciones
de Brasil la campaña electoral está
oficialmente cerradas los candidatos ya
no pueden pedir el voto a sus electores
ni se puede hacer publicidad en los
medios de comunicación sin embargo la
ley electoral de Brasil permite que se
celebre en mítines paseatas y eventos
con alto parlantes hasta las 22 horas de
hoy es una peculiaridad del sistema
electoral brasileños que también permite
publicar encuestas hasta el día mismo de
las elecciones es por esta razón que el
presidente
está hoy en San Pablo protagonizando un
desfile de motocicleta un tipo de
eventos que viene promocionando desde el
año pasado también su contrincante Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva hará una pasea del
centro de esta misma ciudad San Pablo
que es el colegio electoral más grande
del país con más de 34 millones de
electores los sondeos todos
prácticamente dan por ganador a Lula la
gran pregunta es si conseguirás en la
primera vuelta tiene en teoría el 50% de
las intenciones de Voto frente al 36% de
bolsonaro hemos visto en los últimos
días una campaña de reconocidos
economistas intelectuales artistas a
favor de que Lula gane la primera vuelta
un voto Útil para evitar posibles
disturbios y ataques contra la
democracia el clima está tenso hasta el
punto que el tribunal subrero electoral
ha prohibido el transporte de arma y
municiones a coleccionistas en el fin de
semana de las elecciones y al día
siguiente esta da una idea de cómo es el
clima en este momento en